atterrissage en israël puis direction ça
got pour partager une bouteille de vin
local à son nom mike pompéo reçu
chaleureusement pour le tout premier
déplacement d'un chef de la diplomatie
américaine dans une colonie israélienne
en cisjordanie occupée
tout un symbole car washington vient de
décider de labelliser les exportations
israéliennes des colonies implantées en
territoire palestinien comme provenant
directement d'israël et un autre geste
fort concernant le mouvement de boycott
contre israël
nous considérons la campagne mondiale
anti israël bds comme antisémite
je veux que vous sachiez que nous allons
immédiatement prendre des mesures pour
identifier les organisations impliquées
dans la campagne de haine menée par le
bds et retirer le soutien du
gouvernement américain à ses troupes
le moment est venu cette mesure vise la
campagne nommée bds boycott économique
culturel et scientifique
désinvestissement et sanctions animée
par plusieurs ong qui dénoncent
l'occupation et la colonisation
israélienne des territoires palestiniens
de son côté l'autorité palestinienne
condamne cette visite
cette décision fait fi de façon
flagrante du droit international
elle ne permettra pas de légitimer les
colonies israéliennes qui disparaîtront
tôt ou tard la communauté internationale
doit prendre ses responsabilités et
mettre en pratique ces résolutions
mais mike pompéo poursuit son programme
après prague hot le plateau du golan
autres territoires occupés syriens cette
fois ces quatre dernières années
les etats unis ont affiché un soutien
inconditionnel à israël
reconnaissance de jérusalem comme
capitale approbation de la souveraineté
israélienne sur la partie du plateau du
golan prise à la syrie lors de la guerre
de 1967 appui à la colonisation en
cisjordanie est remise en cause de
l'accord de vienne sur le nucléaire
iranien avec les annonces de ce jeudi
l'administration trump celle son appui à
israël
tout juste deux mois avant l'investiture
du futur locataire de la maison blanche